you warm up but you can watch over all
right so let's do
Jack bring it back
fast don't drop it when you bring it
back okay so go slow boom okay so it
needs to go back at that same level as
you're bringing it back slowly you see
it's coming down and then it comes up it
goes back and it covers that
there
back back faster than it goes out that's
your mind there you go you dropped
anything don't try to kill the M
touch don't try to kill the M but
there's no Mass on the M do that it it's
just about te you keep dropping it
now just the
cross so not the jab just the
cross don't try kill the M it's not the
heavy
back don't lose your ground
back Jack
St what
you're keep your eye on it just like
just like the shooting the pistol or
shooting the basket okay don't let your
eyes on her
around and and be a small
Target okay don't look at the Val
look small
okay there you
go
okay boom boom it's going to come back
I'm going to come over top Bob and weave
under it and come back over top right
cross
boom drop your hands on the on the Bob
and then find the small Target
[Music]
again
okay hold your
hands go boom boom boom okay right right
here in the LI right St there do you
feel it right in there you feel that
kind
of stiff
tenderness
okay don't again don't try the power on
the on the TR Techni this body shot is
close keep the elbow close to your body
I'm go slow again slow slow so I can see
it one two boom so watch my watch my
body come here stay still so on the body
blow I'm going to
rotate don't stay on your feet
rotate okay so here would be your cross
and here's that
body okay I'll do it again I'll do it
again okay boom boom and I'm going to
step
you boom boom step and tight
okay slow slow one two step step other
foot step that's it
boom balance slow one two boom H don't
look away from the target
okay I'm looking at you still do you see
look my body's turning don't look over
here slow this one's slow one two step
boom good good this hand on the on the
hook to the body is one two look how it
stays here you see and it's going to
Loop to free that shoulder free the
shoulder so it's up freeze the shoulder
that's when it drops okay one two no
okay boom back up and is where where I
bring it in okay so the movement is here
boom jab cross boom in okay
slow one two step and don't don't it's
not a big I don't move my fist in the
wind up okay I kind of roll roll my
shoulder my shoulder out this way the
elbow goes out don't go like
this okay good stay there turn your
fist turn your
fist diagonal you see tight to your body
and don't try for range okay I I'll give
it to you one time see you
feel this is like a chopping
a chopping blow okay so I'm not going to
go boom and try to go through want to
hit right underneath the skin just this
got tight
okay
slow two tight move in tight get close
good boom diagonally up tight diagonally
up and don't start overing
okay so if you can't reach me there what
should you do yeah that's
it short chopping back in back out back
out back in boom boom boom that's it
back
out boom
good
bring it back up so after I after I hit
my hands right back up you see that
don't don't leave it down there okay
back in the
middle
up and for BCE I'm going to come over
the top and you'll blob out and then
bounce out so slow one
two there you
go
make sure you hit that shot don't don't
duck before the strike
comes you see get your eyes
up there you
go
there okay so so here here's what I'm
talking
about uh you you're going to want to
step with your stance you're going to
want to strike with your stance you see
that so you're not going to want to
strike like that get it so you're going
to want your foot oh on the ground Pro
okay and so what happens is as you're
dancing around your hands are kind of on
a gyro you see that and so from your
hands the guy knows boom when that
thing's going to come so you you have to
have your I guess your hands should be
on a gyro instead they're just going
with the ship okay so my hands are going
to be here I try to keep them there no
matter how much I'm jumping you see my
hands stay right there they not going to
go like this so as I'm moving moving
moving and that hand comes right out
from there okay I'll try it
again
good
better
okay you can you
keep all right so I'm going one two wol
he I try to dance out he's clenching up
on me
okay one two boom HP all right make sure
your hands aren't caught in the clinch
okay one
two all right I'm going to take this
foot and get to the side and the hand
that's down it's going to go reverse
Ridge hand to the groin and just check
that leg cuz my groin is open so my
hands are here where you okay okay and
then you could move your hands so you
can see and this foot goes here and I
come in and hit here in the groin and I
check that leg at the same time okay so
again one
two inside
the
okay let's try
it now make a circle turn your hips into
the strike lower your height by dropping
your rear knee there you go
right good and get that leg check in
there at the same time turn your body
into
it slower smoother
good get the leg
CH move again on that line do you see
that
line
all right so watch watch this it's it's
very subtle but as I go P I'm inside
that his
grab inside the eye of the stord there's
a Yin space in there and I'm going to
move into it okay instead of staying
here oh his chest has got me he's got
downward weight right here you see that
stay where you are here we are you feel
that difference right there trist okay
so not here where I get all that I got
to be where there's room inside okay and
that's where I can hit okay so it's very
subtle all right ideally I would try to
get out but there's a Yin space in there
right in here right in here I'm free
come in
okay Bo boom boom feel how are you going
to know where that it is cuz he pressed
there so I yield do you see he pressed
there and I yield and I hang out in here
and by the time it closes beyond that
I've already hit him okay so you got to
feel it no different than he pushes
right he's pushing and you yield not
ahead of it not behind it right with him
going okay it's exactly the same here
one two inside inside there where you're
loose inside
that
inside inside you see how I fit in
there hold it right here and there's
your punch right there
boom
hold
it
inside hold straight right okay here we
go
yes
boom hold hit boom turn your hips drrive
your foot there you go
all feel
it good good okay so cool the spacing
the m is good this uh I come in boom and
I'm in you feel that all right okay so
at that is where I should have hid him
you get I shouldn't be here and then go
so at one two pull in I'm coming in okay
try it again he should in other words
land on the ridge hand to the
Gro good get the leg check is on the on
the top do you understand cuz he could
be
going right you're
here and he could be going this way
so you want to check that leg I'm hit
the
okay good boom and I'm doing a short
another chopping punch right to that jaw
hinge you get it so just like you went
to the body that's where you hit that
thing
move your body into the
strike good time good
M
good move into that last strike all
right move into it take your left foot
and step into
it boom there you
go
all right so uh whenever you're going to
do whenever you're going to grab it so
if I'm going to grab you you see that
I'm going to grab you I'm going to grab
you into to support that punch boom you
feel that so I might as well hit
you you understand so when I'm doing my
jab you come over the top pull you try
to clench right I'm going to hit you
boom right here and this will twist
through it you see that don't hold it
there hit it and punch the Target off
the ground you get it so I can't I don't
want to hit you don't want to hit Taylor
like I just hit you but you should still
go through it you see that difference
okay try
to and and don't just grab show that it
would have been a palm heel strike
either the jaw hinge the mastoid the
eard drum okay all all
right good timing good boom pop and
again diagonally
vertical good boom boom punch through
you're punching horizontal it's this
way boom that's better try again and
move the left foot into the
strip
good good one
more good all right Ty Taylor you
try